avec nous sébastien mêlée directeur de
l'agencé locale de l'énergie et du
climat de saint-quentin-en-yvelines plus
connu sous le nom de l'alec sky bonjour
bonjour alors là l'express est une
association créée en 2001 par la
communauté d'agglomération
leur mission c'est informer sensibiliser
et accompagner les habitants les
entreprises et les collectivités sur les
questions de transition environnementale
alors comment s'est passé le
déconfinement qu avec vous et comment
vous avez vous repris votre activité
alors très progressivement évidemment
mais on a la chance à lagence de pas
avoir vraiment stopper l'activité
c'est à dire que l'été c'est une période
propice aux bilans on est plutôt nous en
grosse activité sur la période hivernale
période de chauffe c'est là on est en
visite où on est le plus sollicité par
les particuliers donc on a on a pu tous
leurs usages du télétravail et notamment
maintenir un certain niveau de
permanence donc l'alternance physique
rendez vous ont bien évidemment été
stoppée néanmoins on a conservé on a
innové aussi on a on a découvert les
permanences en visioconférence et on a
continué à assurer le service au moins
téléphonique
vous avez organisé différents oui d'inr
notamment tout à fait ne pouvant pas
touché ou informés via nous ateliers
habituels les particuliers les usagers
du territoire
on a trouvé une solution qui est pas
très original pour cette période l'homme
etc et le webinaire qui ont assez bien
marché on a eu on a fait le plein à
chaque fois de d'inscrits par rapport
on va dire des bonnes capacités pour
pouvoir échanger puis sont visionnables
sur le compte youtube de l'alec donc
n'hésitez pas aussi si vous n'avez pas
assisté à aller visionner ces les
webinaires d'informations sûres sur les
grandes caractéristiques de la mission
que ce soit sur la rénovation ou sur des
écogestes on peut appliquer tous les
jours alors l'une des thématiques du
sommet abordés lors de ces webinaire
c'est les astuces pour conserver son
logement au frais et ça tombe bien parce
que cette semaine le thermomètre dépasse
les 30 degrés est ce que vous pouvez
nous donner quelques astuces et donner
quelques astuces aux téléspectateurs
pour conserver leur logement au frais
face à ces
de température oui tout à fait on avait
lu des informations pas très bonne sur
l'arctique où on a on a atteint des
records à 37 38 degrés ces derniers
jours malheureusement ça fait que
confirmer les scénarios du giec même
peut-être les plus optimistes les
astuces pour le logement pour rester au
frais je dirais que la première c'est
d'avoir déjà un logement bien isolé un
logement bien isolé c'est la garantie de
conserver un niveau de fraîcheur de nos
logements sans engager de travaux ou en
attendant il ya quand même des astuces
c'est déjà se protéger enfin ventiler et
aérer fr une circulation d'air et puis
se protéger en fête du soleil c'est les
rayons du soleil qui apporte aussi la
chaleur donc fermer les rideaux des
choses comme ça bien s'hydrater ça
permet aussi tout simplement de ne tenir
la chaleur il ya des paramètres de santé
qui sont très fortement lié à ces
paramètres caniculaire où il de confort
pour revenir on l'a vu un cette pandémie
a entraîné un choc économique la
priorité des gouvernements dans le monde
entier aujourd'hui c'est la relance
économique
une relance qui se veut parfois verte
pour assurer aussi une transition
environnementale comment vous au
quotidien vous agissez auprès des
entreprises pour justement les
accompagner dans cette transition
environnementale
alors c'est une de nos missions
effectivement c'est déjà travaillé sur
la maîtriser l'énergie
on suit à la lettre ce qu'on appelle la
démarche négawatt qui était une démarche
simplement de bon sens un qui a été
conçu par un panel de scientifiques de
l'association négawatt qui se décline en
trois volets sobriété efficacité
renouvelables le premier poste d'abord
la sobriété supprimer les gaspillages
on sait sur ce poste là qu'on va
travailler en priorité ça passe par la
maîtrise de l'énergie le suivi des la
maîtrise de ses consommations d'énergie
aussi donc le premier accompagnement
qu'on peut proposer aux notamment
petites entreprises c'est travailler sur
ces postes de maîtrise des consommations
énergétiques ça fait diminuer les
charges
ça va être sur les factures
d'électricité ça peut être l'éclairage
dans une boutique donc là on a un
certain nombre d'actions qu'on peut
proposer aux loups tpe sur une partie du
territoire pouvoir que la reprise si
elle peut se faire dans une
d'une manière un peu plus verte comme
vous dites plus dans l'adéquation avec
la transition énergétique c'est surtout
une opportunité au niveau de l'emploi il
ya aujourd'hui beaucoup d'emplois qui
reste à créer et beaucoup d'opportunités
économiques
donc c'est un vrai levier de relance
cette transition énergétique
pour conclure peut-être qu'on ne le voit
pas encore mais croyez vous que cette
urgence sanitaire qu'on a connus ces
derniers mois va permettre de prendre
conscience ou en tout cas de renforcer
la prise de conscience autour de
l'urgence climatique
d'une certaine manière oui alors sur
l'urgence climatique peut-être pas
directement pour les moins convaincus
mais en tout cas elle a fait la mis en
avant cette période
combien de passes et la mise en avant
des des nouvelles possibilités soit en
termes de consommation en termes de vie
ensemble au niveau de la santé aussi des
nouvelles préoccupations qui vont
rejoindre de toute façon les thématiques
climatiques qui sont très transversal et
très globale quand on parle de
changement climatique ou transition
écologique énergétique
on touche en fait à tous les domaines
soit le bâtiment la rénovation avec les
les entreprises c'est un nouveau gros
sujets aussi notamment via la plateforme
repères habitat et puis l'émission
conseil mais ça passe aussi par des
questions de santé de mobilité on a vu
on a pu mesurer concrètement l'impact
d'un changement assez radical de
mobilité aujourd'hui sur nos territoires
ça c'est vraiment très transversal ça
touche tout donc je pense que chacun en
fonction des thématiques qui lui sont
peut-être les plus chères auquel il
serait plus sensible va trouver matière
à procès dans la transition énergétique
merci sébastien mais les gars merci à
vous directeur de l'agencé locale de
l'énergie et du climat de saint quentin
en yvelines